what's very important is we get our
economy growing we unleash investment
right across the united kingdom i'm here
at a whiskey distillery talking about
how it's important that we back
industries like the whiskey industry we
get more investment in that's why it's
important we keep taxes low we unleash
investment by changing the rules we have
at the moment which are old eu rules and
we turbo charge growth right across our
economy that is the best way to deliver
better wages but also more jobs and more
growth
keerstarmers says that labour would
freeze energy prices for everyone goes a
lot further than yourself or rishi sunak
are you failing to grasp the scale of
the problem facing households at the
moment
we're still in the leadership contest at
the moment
now
my priority
is reducing taxes so people can keep
more of their own money at the same time
as making sure we boost energy supply
it's wrong to just keep sticking
plasters on this problem what we
actually need to do is make sure we are
unleashing more energy for example from
the north sea we're investing in
technologies like nuclear and we're
finding more renewable energy as well we
need to solve this problem
for the long term
do you think your comments about nicola
sturgeon being an attention seeker have
alienated voters and if if you do win
this leadership race
will you be able to ignore her
well i'm absolutely passionate about
scotland and the united kingdom i grew
up in paisley
i've spent my primary school years there
and what i want is to deliver for the
people of scotland and that's what i'm
focused on
what can you do to help the people of
scotland in terms of the cost of living
crisis and the high price of energy at
the moment well the first thing i will
do is reduce people's taxes we shouldn't
have raised national insurance it's cost
ordinary families money i'd also have a
temporary moratorium on the green energy
levy to save people money on their fuel
bills and also boost energy supply to
bring prices down
how
can you show up support for the union
there is one poll saying today that
whether yourself or versus sooner when
there will be a boost for independence
how can you show that support for the
union here
well first of all we had a referendum in
2014. it was clear it was a one in a
generation referendum and the scottish
people voted for the union for the
united kingdom and i'm absolutely
committed to delivering for scotland
delivering jobs and growth and
opportunity working closely with douglas
ross to take on the snp who've been
failing scottish people whether that's
on education whether that's on health or
whether it's on the transport system i
just want to check about the
windfall tax do you rule out any further
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
and are you committed to imposing the
regime that was put in place to tax
offshore companies by rushing synagogue
i'm not in favour of windfall taxes
because fundamentally what they do is
they put off investors into our country
and what we need is we need jobs and
growth we need more opportunities for
fantastic people for example investing
in this distillery we need to attract
more of that if we have arbitrary taxes
that puts off investment and it stops
growth in the long term